- [Instructor] A zucchini
squash was peeled
and cut into six identical cubes.
After being weighed, each cubed was soaked
in a different sucrose
solution for 24 hours
in an open container and
at a constant temperature
of 21 degrees Celsius.
The cubes were then removed
from the sucrose solutions,
carefully blotted on paper
towels and weighed again.
The percent change in
mass due to a net gain
or loss of water was
calculated for each cube
and the results are
shown in the graph below.
I put the graph to the
right right over here.
A straight line is drawn on the graph
to help in estimating results from other
sucrose concentrations not tested.
Using the straight line
on the graph above,
calculate the water potential in bars
of the zucchini squash
at 21 degrees Celsius.
Give your answer to one decimal place.
So pause this video and see
if you can have a go at it.
Alright, now let's do this together.
So we have our six
cubes of zucchini squash
and we have each of these data points
are the data for each of those cubes.
So for example, this
data point shows a cube
that was put into a solution that contains
no sucrose and when it
was put into a solution
that contains no sucrose,
it gained 20% mass and that mass would be
from the water going into the cube.
So one way to think about it is
it got put into a solution,
and so you had a net inflow of water
into that sucrose cube, enough
to increase its mass by 20%.
This second data point right over here,
it was put into a solution that is
.20 moles per liter of sucrose
and that also had an increase of mass
but it was a smaller increase of mass.
And then we can go all
the way to the extreme
right over here where
we had a zucchini cube
put into a solution that
had a lot of sucrose in it,
one mole per liter, and there,
you have a net outflow of water.
It deceased the cube's mass by 30%.
So how do we figure
out the water potential
of the zucchini squash?
Well one way to think about it is
we could figure out the water
potential of zucchini squash
is if we put it into a solution
that has a certain sucrose concentration
and if we have no net
inflow or outflow of water
in either direction, that
means that the zucchini squash
and the sucrose solution
have the same water potential
and we see that happening,
at least we can interpellate
it right over here
because if we just follow that line,
it looks like if we were
to put our zucchini cubes,
our zucchini squash cubes
into a sucrose solution
that is, this looks about, let's see.
This would be .3, so let's just call that
0.36 molar solution, 0.36 molar solution.
Well, then it has the same water potential
as that solution because
you have no net inflow
or outflow of water.
So the zucchini squash water potential
is going to be the same
as the water potential
of a solution of sucrose
that has 0.36 moles per liter
so we just have to figure out
the water potential of that.
Well, the water potential formula we know
and we've seen this in other videos
is equal to our solute potential
plus our pressure potential.
We know that these are open containers,
so the pressure potential is going to be 0
and so we just need to figure
out the solute potential
of our sucrose solution
with this concentration.
Well, we know our solute potential
is going to be equal to negative I,
where this is the ionization constant.
For every molecule of sucrose,
does it disassociate into
when it gets put into water?
Well, sucrose doesn't disassociate it,
so it would just be one times our molarity
times what's sometimes
called a pressure constant
but it's really the same thing as
a universal gas constant you
might have learned in chemistry
times the temperature in Kelvin.
So this is going to be equal to negative,
I already said that this I is one
because the sucrose just stays sucrose
when you put it in water, so negative one
times 0.36, I'll write
the units, moles per liter
times R and if you're doing
something like an AP test,
they actually give you these formulas
and they even give you R
as being 0.0831 liter bars
per mole Kelvin and then times
the temperature in Kelvin.
Well if we're dealing
with 21 degrees Celsius,
we just add 273 to that,
so times 294 Kelvin
and now we can just
get our calculator out.
Negative one times .36
times .0831 times 294
is equal to if I round
to one decimal place,
it's gonna be negative 8.8.
Negative 8.8 and the
units work out as well.
Moles cancel with moles,
liters cancel with liters,
Kelvin cancels with Kelvin,
and we're just with,
left with negative 8.8 bars.
And we are done.